او مكانه تعرف بسله الفاكهه الاوكرانيه لم
تعد بالحلاوه والالوان نفسها فرائحه
التعذيب تنبعث من كل مكان هناك مدعون
اوكرانيون وجهوا اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم
حرب لاربعه من افراد الحرس الوطني الروسي
وهو جهاز اسسه بوتين قبل سبع سنوات ويخضع
مباشره له بعض ضحايا ساعدوا بالتعرف على
المتهمين الاربعه من خلال صور لوحده الحرس
كما ساهمت معلومات استخباراتيه واعتراضات
هاتفيه بالتعرف عليهم احد عشر مركز احتجاز
تم اكتشافهم حتى اللحظه هذه المراكز مجهزه
بغرف تعذيب شهدت مئات الجرائم بما فيها
العنف الجنسي والاعدامات الوهميه وفق
شهاداتنا جيم الضحايا تعرضوا للضرب وحرم
بعضهم من الرعايه الصحيه فيما ابلغ 17
محتجازا عن تعرضهم للتعذيب الجنسي
بالصدمات الكهربائيه
اسفرت عمليات والتعذيب وفق نيويورك تايمز
عن مقتل ثلاثه اوكرانيين بينهم امراه
مضيفه ان هذه القضيه واحده من اولى
القضايا التي ظهرت بعد التحقيقات الادعاء
العام الاوكراني اكد مواصله الاعمال
الهادفه الى تحديد مواقع غرف التعذيب
والاحتجاز غير القانوني مبينا انه يريد
التعرف على جميع الضحايا فخرسون الواقعه
جنوبي اوكرانيا سيطرت عليها روسيا لنحو
ثمانيه اشهر قبل استعادتها مجددا من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه في نوفمبر الماضي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات